I think news organizations can survive a
digital revolution this is a very fast
moving picture I would say if you asked
me to predict as of today in my
prediction might be different three
months let's say you're in the Cleveland
Plain Dealer what are you going to look
like in 25 years you will be the
dominant newsgathering organization
Cleveland Ohio probably you will have
somewhat fewer employees on the news
side than you do now but you'll still
exist and you'll still be profitable
you'll be exploring creative
arrangements you know freelance contract
part-time all the things that doesn't
has to come from the magazine business
know and love so well in the newspaper
business you will have your primary
audience on the internet your print
audience will be much smaller than it is
now you'll be charging three four to
five times as much for daily newspaper
delivery as you do now and as a result
the daily newspaper will be a more sort
of elite product that offers more kind
of specialized analytic information it
will feel more like a sort of mini New
York Times it'll be pitch to advertisers
as such on the internet you'll have a
free home page that has more sort of
general and has a big circulation and
then inside of that they'll be what's
known in the trade as verticals or
channels that are about very very thinly
shaved specific interests and you'll
probably have to pay to enter those
something about your high school
football team very specific information
about this suburb where you live things
like that the New York Times is sort of
a magazine as the feel of a magazine so
in that sense yes it'll be a magazine it
won't be printed as a magazine
but it will feel more magazine II and
less newspaper but the main thing is I
think these news organizations will live
on as news organizations in their
communities they won't just go to
business but they won't be understood as
newspapers